DONALD TRUMP AND THE BREAKING OF
AMERICA.
IT'S TRULY WELL REPORTED.
AN EXCELLENT, EXCELLENT BOOK.
I HIGHLY RECOMMEND IT.
AS YOU KNOW, THE FORMER
PRESIDENT IS DOUBLING DOWN NOW
ON HIS SUPPORT FOR WALKER.
CAN WALKER SURVIVE THIS?
>> HE CAN, WOLF.
IT'S GOING TO DEPEND ON YOU
KNOW, HOW SIGNIFICANT AN ISSUE
THIS IS PARTICULARLY FOR
EVANGELICAL VOTERS IN GEORGIA,
BUT I THINK WALKER IS GOING TO
BE YET ANOTHER TEST IN THIS POST
DONALD TRUMP REPUBLICAN PARTY OF
WHAT VOTERS ARE WILLING TO
TOLERATE.
WE SAW THEY WERE WILLING TO
TOLERATE A NUMBER OF
CONTROVERSIES WITH TRUMP.
THIS ONE IS SOMEWHAT DIFFERENT.
YOU KNOW, BUT WALKER HAS BEEN
SHOWING STAYING POWER IN THIS
RACE.
YOU KNOW, DESPITE ALLEGATIONS
RELATED TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
OVER THE COURSE OF THE PAST
YEAR.
MORE THAN THAT.
I THINK IT'S JUST TOO SOON TO
SAY.
I WOULD NOT ASSUME IT IS GOING
TO KNOCK HIM OUT.
>> YOU INTERVIEWED TRUMP
OBVIOUSLY FOR YOUR NEW BOOK AND
THE NAME HERSCHEL WALKER CAME UP
IN YOUR INTERVIEWS.
THIS WAS BEFORE THE LATEST
ALLEGATIONS EMERGED AGAINST HIM.
I WANT OUR VIEWERS TO LISTEN TO
WHAT TRUMP TOLD YOU ABOUT
WALKER'S CONTROVERSIAL PAST.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> IN GEORGIA, THINK ABOUT
GEORGIA.
IN GEORGIA, HERSCHEL, THEY DID
THE BALLOT TO HERSCHEL.
YOU KNOW HOW GREAT A FOOTBALL
PLAYER IS?
YOU KNOW HE WAS IN UNIVERSITY OF
GEORGIA, HE WAS THE BEST
FOOTBALL PLAYER IN THE NATION.
BY FAR.
HE'S THE BEST FOOTBALL PLAYER IN
THE HISTORY OF GEORGIA.
AND FOR THE MOST PART, IT'S
TRUE.
AS A RUNNING BACK, HE'S A TOP
THREE OR FOUR RUNNING BACK.
>> BUT HE HAS A COMPLICATED
PERSONAL HISTORY.
>> TEN YEARS AGO, MAYBE IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN A PROBLEM.
20 YEARS AGO IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
A BIGGER PROBLEM.
I DON'T THINK IT'S A PROBLEM
TODAY.
>> WHY IS THAT?
>> BECAUSE THE WORLD IS
CHANGING.
>> WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT
RESPONSE, MAGGIE?
>> I THINK THAT DONALD TRUMP IS
AWARE OF HIS OWN ROLE IN THE
WORLD CHANGING AS HE PUT IT,
WHICH IS HE SEES IT AS HE
SURVIVED ALL KINDS OF SCANDALS.
OTHER PEOPLE CAN, TOO.
DONALD TRUMP IS A UNIQUE FIGURE.
HE HAD BEEN PART OF POP CULTURE
IN THE COUNTRY FOR DECADES
BEFORE HE BECAME A CANDIDATE AND
VOTERS FELT BONDED TO HIM IN
WAYS THAT ISN'T NECESSARILY TRUE
WITH EVERYONE.
I THINK THAT WALKER AS A FORMER
SPORTS STAR STARTS WITH BASE OF
SUPPORT THAT OTHERS DO NOT, BUT
TRUMP LIKES TO THINK OTHER
PEOPLE CAN SURVIVE SCANDAL
BECAUSE I'VE SHOWN THEM HOW TO
DO IT.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ALLEGATIONS
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IN HIS PAST
AND TRUMP IS ESSENTIALLY SAYING
IT DOESN'T MATTER ANYMORE.
WE'LL FIND OUT IF THAT'S TRUE.
>> WE WILL.
AS YOU KNOW, TRUMP IS NOW
HIMSELF IN WHAT'S BEING CALLED
SURVIVAL MODE AS HE FACES
MULTIPLE INVESTIGATIONS
INCLUDING HIS HANDLE OF
DOCUMENTS AT MAR-A-LAGO.
I WANT TO READ AN EXCERPT FROM
YOUR BOOK ON HIS HANDLING OF
CLASSIFIED MATERIAL.
I'M QUOTING.
HE TWEETED A SENSITIVE PICTURE
OF DAMAGE AT AN IRANIAN SPACE
FACILITY WITHOUT WAITING FOR
OFFICIALS TO INK OUT DETAILS
BECAUSE HE LIKED HOW THE IMAGE
LOOKED.
IF YOU TAKE OUT THE
CLASSIFICATION, THAT'S THE SEXY
PART HE PROTESTED AS THEY TRIED
TO MAKE CHANGES.
WHAT DOES THAT SAY TO YOU ABOUT
HIS FASCINATION WITH SUCH
SENSITIVE GOVERNMENT DOCUMENTS?
>> I THINK HE SHOWS A TOTAL
DISINTEREST IN ACKNOWLEDGING
THERE ARE SECRETS THAT THE
NATION HOLDS THAT ARE NOT ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP PROMOTING HIMSELF
OR USING WHAT HE THINKS IS COOL.
IT'S THAT THESE ARE THINGS THAT
EXIST THAT ARE PART OF SENSITIVE
INTELLIGENCE GATHERING
OPERATIONS.
THEY CAN PUT MISSIONS OR PEOPLE
AT RISK IF THESE PIECES OF
INFORMATION GET OUT AND IT'S
JUST NEVER BEEN SOMETHING HE
CARES ABOUT.
ONE OF THE THINGS I EXPLORE IN
THE BOOK IS THAT TRUMP TREATS
EVERYTHING AS IF IT'S FLAT AND
DEVOID OF CONTEXT.
THAT'S ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF IT.
IT'S AS IF IT WAS ANOTHER
TROPHY.
LIKE WHEN HE WOULD KEEP
SHAQUILLE O'NEILL'S SHOE AT
TRUMP TOWER.
THIS FALLS IN THE SAME
CATEGORIES.
>> YOU SAY EVERYBODY YOU
REPORTED FOR THIS NEW BOOK, THE
THING THAT UPSET HIM THE MOST,
REFERRING TO TRUMP.
WAS THAT HE FLUSHED DOCUMENTS
DOWN THE TOILET.
DO YOU HAVE ANY GUESSES AS TO
WHY THAT PROVOKED HIM?
>> I THINK BECAUSE HE FELT IT
WAS PERSONAL WHEN IN REALITY, IT
WAS A STORY ABOUT HOW HE WAS
HANDLING DOCUMENTS AND IT'S NOT
SURPRISING TO ME THAT THAT WAS A
THING THAT HE GOT UPSET ABOUT,
BUT I THINK IT WAS IMPORTANT
INFORMATION GIVEN THAT HE WAS
THE PRESIDENT.
>> THERE'S OF COURSE LOTS OF
SPECULATION ABOUT WHAT TRUMP'S
POLITICAL FUTURE HOLDS, BUT YOU
SAY TRUMP'S HEART ISN'T
NECESSARILY IN POLITICS NOW THE
WAY IT WASN'T WAS.
WHY IS THAT?
>> BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
DIFFERENT WHEN SOMEONE HAS BEEN
A PRESIDENT AND THEY ARE BACK TO
DOING THE SAME THING THEY HAD
DONE BEFORE THEY HAD POWER.
YOU KNOW, HE'S DOING THESE
RALLIES AGAIN.
I DON'T THINK THAT FEELS GREAT
TO HIM AND IT'S NOT HUGELY
SURPRISING TO ME THAT HE FEELS
THAT WAY.
HE MAY GET MORE INTO IT IF HE
DECLARES A CAMPAIGN.
HE TENDS TO ENJOY A FIGHT ONCE
HE'S IN IT AS OPPOSED TO THE
LEAD UP TO IT.